trillions of microorganisms live on our
skin noses and throughout our
gastrointestinal tracts the species that
live in our GI tract called the gut
microbiota have a profound impact on how
we feel every day our resident gut
bacteria constantly monitor other
microbiota and the cells that make up
our digestive system when a stimulus
appears in the gut environment it binds
to a cellular receptor enzyme called
histidine kinase on the bacterial
surface which passes the signal into the
cell the signal activates the internal
response regulator which moves and binds
to the bacterial DNA causing regulation
of certain gene expressions in response
to that specific stimulus
by hijacking these natural signaling
systems we have genetically programmed
ecoli one of the many bacteria that
lived naturally in our guts to monitor
and report the health of the gut
environment these bacteria could be
given to people as a probiotic pill
which would release the engineered eco
light in the gut to live and proliferate
when a change to the gut environment
occurs such as inflammation the stimulus
is sensed by the engineered Ecoline the
following signal transduction triggers
the expression of the introduced gene to
produce a protein
which changes the color of the
probiotics periodically some bacteria
are shed reporting the presence of the
inflammation with a visible color change
of the human waste in this manner a
physician could get a clearer picture of
digestive health without the need for
any costly invasive procedures in
addition to being used for Diagnostics
the probiotic could function as a
therapeutic tool through a similar
process of genetic engineering the
probiotics detect invading pathogenic
bacteria and emits toxins to
specifically kill the pathogen but does
not harm beneficial microbiota the
genetically engineered equal I could
radically transform the way we diagnose
and treat gastrointestinal disorders